Hello.
This is the metamorphosis
of the cube.
I'm professor Erik
Demaine in CSAIL at MIT.
And this is joint work
with Martin Demaine,
Ana [INAUDIBLE],, Joseph
O'Rourke, [? Arina ?] Pachinko.
And we're looking here
at different foldings
and unfoldings of
surfaces in 3D.
Here we have our friend the
cube and a familiar unfolding
of the cube called
the cross unfolding.
And it turns out that if you
change the creases in the cross
and fold it up a
different way, you
can make all sorts of
different convex polyhedra.
Here we have a very simple
one, a flat doubly covered
quadrilateral.
But all the others are
going to be non-flat.
So we saw the cube,
got the quadrilateral.
The next one is a
pentahedron, five sides.
And we form exactly the surface
of this bilaterally symmetric
pentahedron.
On the other hand, if we
change the creases in this way,
then we get a tetrahedron.
This is my favorite because
the little tab fits exactly
into the pocket at exactly the
surface of that tetrahedron,
not a regular tetrahedron,
but a tetrahedron nonetheless.
And finally, if we change
the creases in this way,
we get an octahedron.
And all of these polyhedra
are computed automatically
with an algorithm that
given a flat shape
tells you all of the
different convex polyhedra
that it can glue up into.
So here we had five
different shapes, the cube,
the quadrilateral, the
pentahedron, the tetrahedron,
and the octahedron.
But for different polygons,
you get different 3D shapes.
Just to give you an idea
of the range of unfolding,
unfolding is a lot harder.
If I give you a
3D surface and you
cut it up and try to unfold
it, when does it overlap
is a big question.
That was an example of a
non-overlapping unfolding.
There's quite a variety
in what you could do.
Here's a particularly fun
unfolding we called the stop
light unfolding of the cube.
It looks like a stop light.
And here's one example of
another 3D convex polyhedron
you can fold it up into,
which we call the spaceship
for technical reasons.
And again, the
algorithm automatically
computes all the
different 3D convex
polyhedra you can glue
that flat shape into.
Here we go back to the cube.
And this is ongoing research
in computational geometry.